so you are head hunted to investigate a
grooming gang yeah how do you get from
that to sitting here where you've
resigned from the police having
attempted to bring light to the issue
being fobbed off ignored Etc tell us
about all that well that that job that I
was first um recruited for was called
operation Augusta and it was
2004 um and um a little girl who was 15
called Victoria agolia had um d died
actually in Rochdale um she'd been
horrendously groomed and sexually abused
she was living in care and one of her
abusers had given her an overdose of
drugs which led to her death her death
alongside that at exactly the same time
um a documentary team were making
documentary um in Keithley in South
Yorkshire um and that documentary was
called edge of the city and they had
uncovered a problem in Keithley where
Young young vulnerable workingclass
white girls were being uh groomed um
sexually abused and exploited by gangs
of predominantly Pakistani men um and
the powers that be within the police I
now know um feared that when that
documentary went out there would be a
public outcry and at the same time
Victoria had died in Manchester so with
hindsight I know that GMP greater
Manchester police put together a small
team of officers to um kind of derail
the criticism that we were doing nothing
about that case um but the program went
out um and there wasn't the public
outcry that was expected and so greater
Manchester police in their wisdom
deliberately and intentionally shut down
that job uh the official reasoning is
now um from the Independent review in
2020 that the chief con conable the
assistant chief Constable's head of
crime in GMP made the conscious and
deliberate decision that they would
close down that job because they would
not put resources into it now when they
closed it down uh Constantine we had
over 100 pedophiles on a database that
we knew were abusing children we had
about three dozen children um most of
whom were living in care who were being
raped on a daily basis um that happened
at exactly the time that my husband died
of terminal bowel cancer I went off work
for a couple of months um to nurse him
in his his last weeks when I came back
to work that job had died a death so
Magie sorry to interrupt just it's
complicated I know I know it's not that
it's complicated it's it's hard to
believe frankly what you're saying is
the police the Poli the senior police
officers created an investigation yeah
in order to deflect attention from
failings yes and then when the failings
went public and didn't generate a
backlash they shut down the
investigation that they created to cover
up for that they closed it in his track
even though you knew about hundreds of
pedophiles who were Abus they abandoned
all those young children to their abuse
and furthermore they allowed those 100
pedophiles and more to continue to abuse
for another 50 15 years and it's really
only because I began to when I resigned
which is further down the road that I
never forgot those children and pretty
much every interview I do I refer to
Victoria and I refer to those children
because that is not why I join the
police you know the police are there to
prosecute pedophiles you don't just
suddenly decide that these kids don't
matter you you don't do it in my book
that's not why I joined the police but I
couldn't get any answers I was told told
there was no evidence well I know that
was wrong cuz I was on that job I knew
who those kids were um and it's just
wrong but I was pretty powerless to do
anything you know i' just lost my
husband I've got four children I was a
single parent and I didn't have a single
piece of paper to prove what I was
saying and in fact none of those rapes
at that point had been recorded So on
paper it didn't exist but it did exist
um and now
20 years later Andy Burnham in
Manchester heard me like rabbiting on on
the radio and he put together an
independent review and the review team
spent uh three years looking at that job
and the official findings were yes there
was a job yes there were 100 pedophiles
yes there were three dozen children and
GMP have now been forced to reopen that
case 20 years too late because those men
you think how many other children those
men have prosecuted so when I say I am
not naive I am not naive because they
deliberately did that so I don't trust
them there is a bigger agenda here and
those kids don't matter and I always say
if those children had belonged to the
chief Constable or Boris Johnson or
Rishi sunak they would have they would
have prosecuted those men with every
breath in their body but those kids
don't have anybody fighting their corner
you know often they come from troubled
backgrounds or they Liv in care and you
know what it is just
unforgivable and you know I'm 20 years
on from it and I have been through a lot
of in those 20 years and I have
thought I would go to prison for
speaking the truth because that's what
GMP said to me when I said I was going
public but the truth is the truth and
police officers this is not about
individual police officers because every
organization has good and bad um I was a
good police officer and I did my
absolute best the people who are the bad
ones are those at the top so when the
chief constable and assistant chief
constables make a deliberate decision to
close a job down like that they should
be in prison I'm afraid they are guilty
of misconduct in a public
office